art is with us in Great Bend Kansas hey
art how are you don't well are you
better than I deserve what's up well I
heard you asking for easy questions
early on so this is an easy one for ya
that I just need you that to settle a
disagreement between my wife and I okay
would Carly Oh about nineteen on our
house $19,000 yes sir Wow in our
emergency fund has somewhere around
twenty to six sitting in it which we
only need about fifteen to sixteen
sitting in that I want to just write a
nineteen thousand dollar check tomorrow
she wants to continue to stay the course
and get it paid off within the next six
months and leave our big fat emergency
fund and so I told her that I have the
Bible on my side because you know you
always say that the the slave is you
know I'm saying
but the borrower slave to the lender you
know the bar slavery Lennox I said I had
the Bible on my side and she said you're
on her side
so we will see what side you're on
mm-hmm well I'm not gonna get in the
same argument because your logic is
flawed with you if you want to argue
with your wife and try to put God on
your side which means the devil's left
for her side that's probably a bad way
to argue with your wife that's oh I
don't think I'd use that line ever again
the rest of the time you're married if
you're wise so um I want Sharon to be
able to stay on Jesus's side with me
while we argue so it's just not a good
idea so yeah you know the the principle
of getting out of debt is scriptural you
are right about that and so what we're
arguing about is not neither one of us
none of the three of us think you should
stay in debt the only discussion is when
you should get out of debt and the baby
steps that we teach tell you to have
three to six months of expenses set
aside and above that you move on to baby
steps four five and six which pays off
the house and baby step six
so based on that if you say fifteen
thousand is your normal correct
emergency fund for three to six months
of
expenses then I would immediately put
$11,000 on the house which would bring
it down to 15,000 and which means you
have 8,000 to go and you're gonna pay
off the house not in six months and not
immediately but somewhere in between
which kind of means you're both right
okay and you're both wrong right sorry
I'm not really compromising I'm sticking
with what I teach right but and I'm and
I'm not going against the Bible either
we need to say that one more time I'm
just deciding when we're gonna implement
in the house of the wise our stores of
choice food and oil save money versus
the borrower is slave to the lender get
out of debt those are two principles I
both strongly believe in and you just
got to have a way to with wisdom to
unfold those and so I think somewhere in
the middle of your all's argument is
actually the wisest course of action
yeah hey thanks for the call dude
you